okay I had some predict I had some
predictions I told you on Friday I said
Mary Elizabeth Winstead is playing
you did but I didn't say anything you
didn't you were like interesting which I
always means the nose which I go I'm
right there you go my other prediction
that I didn't say to your face was that
we're getting a Dave filoni Star Wars
movie announcement I swear to God
it'll be weird what if you're wrong but
I would have appreciated the thought and
said that's so nice if you thank you for
the thought that's okay it's so long
overdue so great I can't wait
um how are you feeling
feel good you know jet lagged but
otherwise really good it's surreal you
know I think it just you know for all
the talk we've had about it it really
just hit me yesterday when we were
rehearsing and I was up on stage uh with
everyone I'm like all right this is
really happening yeah this is going to
be out there
I have a lot of work to do it's surreal
experience and uh you know I appreciate
people's enthusiasm around it and uh I
would dedicate myself to doing the best
job I can that's for sure
during the panel there was like a click
moment for me where it was like we see
Monmouth show up in the Ahsoka trailer
we saw some footage for the Mandalorian
where a certain person is mentioned at
the beginning and it's like all the
pieces are coming together and I believe
culminating in your film that would seem
dare I say logical
you know that would be logical I mean
this is the first day so you don't want
to make too many presumptions there's a
panel tomorrow probably want to check
that out
there might be some news tomorrow I
don't know but you think it's the whole
weekend of this we can't just put it all
in one day we've got to spread some
things out right so there's
be dated by tomorrow because we saw the
back of thrawn's head I'm like who is it
why did you why did you
just why do I think that yeah why would
you think that I mean you gotta you
gotta might not be what if it's not
though that could be like what you just
said now could be like if you said I'm
making a movie and I'm not what if it
wasn't you know it could it could be
something different it could be some
other character entirely it could be I'm
just saying that's a possibility
it's not necessarily true would it yeah
kind of kind of interesting interesting
interesting there's a moment that I like
I think like teared up a little bit when
we have these three pictures and it was
Ahsoka Sabine and Hera what was that
moment like for you I guess and seeing
them all on set together too
that moment was like I'm so glad
we've explained who Mary's playing
so happy that's out because she's
awesome and she did a great job so I'm
really happy for her
um
it's it's weird right those characters
it's not like they're more real now to
me they were always real
but I'm glad we have such great people
playing them I'm glad that people want
to see this story I'm glad that people
cheered and are excited about it I mean
it's I don't know if you really can
understand it all when you're there
writing it and and making it it's it's
just different
um but yeah I look up and I see those
characters when they get up there they
are it just it kind of makes sense I
guess it's a weird way to say it I'm
just glad people you know still seem to
want it because I sure like them and
I've been looking forward to telling
this story if I were to tell 2005 Dave
who just started you're going to be
directing a Star Wars movie what would
you say oh you're crazy yeah I mean I
wasn't I had so much to learn about what
I was doing in animation you I had a
long way to go
um it's really you know George
committing to teaching not just me but
the entire animation team uh how to tell
a better story and how to use the tools
but you know he's the one that kind of
got me interested in even thinking about
live action as a possibility of
something I might might like to do
because of the tools he provided us an
animation because of the way we shot the
Clone Wars differently we didn't do
traditional storyboarding we didn't do
and we did more of a virtual camera
system much more akin to what John was
doing later in uh Jungle Book so
I was learning these tools things this
way of thinking and it started to click
over time is I would sit literally for
hours and watch him edit take things
that we had taught in animation and he
would edit them and make them in
something new and change the story and I
had no ambition to write
anything prior to working on Clone Wars
was George but George was insistent that
if I'm going to be a direct drive to
learn how to write and so I started
writing episodes of homers because of
that so it's really
been an evolution all along the way and
just you're surrounded by great people
you know hopefully you can learn and and
do better but the it's the biggest thing
I talk to young people about it's like
sometimes you're in these positions you
don't have to say anything you have to
listen to the people that know more than
you and absorb and so I mean the look
I'm surrounded by now just the the other
directors uh creative Talent there I'm
still learning all the time and then you
just gotta apply when the moment is
right so the moment's coming and I'm
gonna apply hopefully I already am on
Ahsoka
foreign